myriam vega et son conjoint ont acheté
la maison de leurs rêves en 2015
le jeune couple a contracté une
hypothèque de plus de 450 mille dollars
pour acquérir cet immeuble de trois
logements il le rénover on l'a fait le
même vos bons moments à l'époque ils ont
pu profiter de taux hypothécaires très
faible est ce qu'on se disait
dernièrement 4 6 avait eu lieu il ya
deux ans des taux comme on connaît
aujourd'hui ou ce qui s'en vient on
aurait pu accéder à la propriété aussi
rapidement avec la nouvelle hausse du
taux directeur plusieurs banques ont
décidé d'augmenter leur taux
préférentiel d'un quart de point
les détenteurs d'hypothèques à taux
variable sont les premiers touchés
c'est une hausse qui correspond environ
à 6 $ de plus par mo par tranche de 50
mille dollars dont quelqu'un que 100000
d'hypothèques ça veut dire 12 $ de plus
il ya pour certains c'est un effet qui
est mineure pour d'autres ça peut être
un effet qui plus important avec trois
hausses de taux depuis l'été dernier
accéder au marché immobilier est de plus
en plus difficile surtout qu'ottawa a de
nouveau resserré les règles
hypothécaires
depuis le début de l'année tous les
acheteurs doivent se soumettre à une
simulation de risque pour déterminer
s'ils sont capables de soutenir une
augmentation marquée des taux d'intérêt
résultat les premiers acheteurs se font
de plus en plus rares j'ai des
propriétés pour premiers acheteurs
ça bouge pas ou presque pop presque pas
de visite habituellement il ya quelques
années on arrive à des cours d'eau comme
ça des maisons comme ça que ça se
vendait comme des pains chauds puis là
c'est plus là il ya moins d'acheteurs
moins d'appels moins de visites pour
myriam et ben le secret de la réussite
c'est la discipline ont fait des choix
de vivre d'une façon très simple avoir
une voiture usagée faire pas trop de
sorties
il espère que les taux n'auront pas trop
grimper d'ici la renégociation de leur
hypothèque dans deux ans ici olivier
bachand radio canada montréal
[Musique]